okay and uh from here
i will start my slides uh node conf json
there it goes
hands-on intro to kubernetes uh
specifically for javascript developers
so i'm gonna focus a little bit on
javascript right here
um mainly my focus will be on kubernetes
so it doesn't really matter what
language you're you're working with
um but i'll try to get to keep a focus
on on javascript
so uh where there you go so
if you want to follow along for the
examples
so the first thing i'll be using mini
cube so mini cube is a way to have
um essentially a
mini kubernetes cluster running on your
laptop
i think it's a great uh great way to
actually get an intro to kubernetes you
can actually test it out try it out try
different things
a great way to play with kubernetes
there's also this one so if you don't
want to install anything
or if you are running out of time you
can also use
the catacota right here so this will
give you a kubernetes cluster that you
can use for about an hour
we will have some issues when we come to
ingresses which is a way to expose our
cluster to the outside world
i don't think they work as well with
catacota but you should still be able to
follow along
do most of the steps that we will see
today
now this presentation is required so
you'll be able to watch it afterwards
i will share my slides afterwards and
you will also have access to my github
repo
so what i definitely recommend is trying
to run mini cube
uh install that on your machine if not
today you can definitely
install it afterwards and then you'll be
able to run all the examples that we've
seen today
at your own pace and really explore a
little bit more
we've got a lot of content today so um
so yeah so i'll i'll try to go through
it um and so that we have the time to do
everything
uh i have at the end i some a little bit
more advanced concepts that i wanted to
show
hopefully we'll get the the that will be
able to get there
if not that's fine uh you'll get you'll
still get a lot
and more than enough all right brew
install mini cube
so go ahead install minicube uh i also
forgot i
i just remembered that you also need a
cube ctl and it's not part of mini cube
so cube ctl install is
there it is let me just give you the
link for the
english version all right
i'll post this in zoom so you can also
so if you're using mini cube you also
need cube ctl
which is the command line tool that we
will use
okay so why don't i get started with
this workshop as you're
installing i'll talk a little bit so
first first of all let me introduce
myself hi my name is joel
i work as a developer advocate for red
hat openshift so openshift is a
kubernetes distribution by red hat
um so if you're interested to learn more
uh feel free to reach out to me
afterwards
i am based in ottawa canada so uh yay
canada i saw that andrea is also from
canada here
that's nice i represent uh i love love
love twitter so if
you ever have any questions uh if you if
you want to reach out to me for any
reason after this workshop
um feel free to uh note this so joel
underscore underscore lord is usually
the best way to reach out to me
um i i am a big fan of twitter so i'm
always looking at it
my dms are open so feel free to send me
a direct message or
just a public tweet to say uh how much
you appreciate this workshop and so on
so that
you know it helps me to with my bosses
so all right so we'll be talking about
that uh so charlotte to underscore the
lord if you want to reach out
um let's talk about a little brief
history of well just before i actually
jump into that
let me jump talk a little bit more about
myself because i love to talk about
myself but seriously though i um
i joined red hat about a year and a half
ago now
and i didn't know what kubernetes was
when i joined and i joined as a
developer advocate so my job is to talk
about kubernetes and explain what it
does
um so it was quite a learning a steep
learning curve for me so
um and and i come from a javascript
world so i've been doing javascript
development for over 10 years now
and i did when i started with kubernetes
i didn't even know what a container was
so i had to kind of learn what a
container is and then
learn about kubernetes which is an
orchestration
platform to manage your container so
basically a way to deploy all of your
containers
so there was a lot of things to um to
learn
and this is what i wanted to show you
today so i want to give you like like
that little 90 minutes uh walk through
of
what is kubernetes so that you just so
that you have a sense of it
there's a lot of things i'll try to show
you how it is and how you can use it
with
node.js specifically i'll talk a little
bit on
um i have a vue.js application that
we'll try to deploy today
and so you'll get a sense of how that
works but
really i want to focus on on kubernetes
and how you can deploy those containers
now out of curiosity let's let's see if
i can clear those
again no why can't i um just in the chat
who here works with
containers on a day-to-day basis um i
just want to
get a sense of our crowd today
um and everybody went quiet
all right so i'll assume some people
might be
just so that everybody's on the same
page i'll i'll start by talking a little
bit about containers what they are
just so that i make sure we're sure that
everybody
um is on the same page all the cool kids
are doing it at my job not me though
that is exactly exactly how i feel most
of the time with containers
um now more and more i can see the value
in it and i
i'm starting to use them more and more
um
but yeah that's kind of how i felt i was
like yeah everybody seems to be using it
but i don't see any value in it why
should i even be bothered with that um
kim is saying we run kubernetes in
production today but i have not touched
it
uh much for trying to learn more okay
cool
okay so just so that everybody's on the
same page let's start with a brief
history of container not history
actually i just i'm a big fan of stephen
hawking so
that's why i use that so what is a
container container is a lightweight
standalone executable package of
software that includes everything needed
to run an application
so that includes your code runtime
system tools
system library settings um so really um
how you can see a container is basically
one one giant big executable
zip file that you can then take and and
put that on multiple environments so
because it includes
not only your source code but also all
the runtimes that are required to run it
it makes it very very portable so it
makes it easy to bring that to another
environment
and to reuse it everywhere so that means
that your working environment or your
development environment if you're using
a container-based
environment on your local machine will
be the exact exact same one
as the one that you have in production
so that reduces the number of errors
um you can also take that same
environment and share that with your q a
team
so that reduces a lot of the frictions
that you might have when somebody finds
a bug and it's
uh you know you can't reproduce it on
your environment i'm sure
a lot of us run into that so that's kind
of how you can see
what a container is a good example
one of the first use cases that i had
was one of my friends came to me and
needed help with a php project and i
used to do php back in the days but now
i don't even have php installed on my
machine
right but i was able to spin up a
container very very easily
and it came with an apache server
pre-configured with php
and i was able to immediately put the
code in and i was able to start um
running all of that code so it made it
very very easy and then i had that
environment that was exactly the same as
he did
so it made it very easy to help him out
without having to do
all of that installation and trying to
configure all of my
apache server i don't know if you did it
um i haven't done it in a few years but
it was a nightmare trying to run that on
on a mac and then you've got all that
stuff that you want to delete afterwards
and it's just there's no way to
remove it um all right so we've got
people sharing gifts now i'm curious
let's see um
let's share this with the team whatever
you want so it hopefully it's
safe for work uh it works on my machine
then we'll ship your machine
and that is how docker was born that's
pretty much uh that's a very good
analogy
uh so basically it really helps you to
be able to share that environment so you
don't have to
ship your laptop to your customers
um so to start a container you'll you'll
have something like that so we'll be
using a lot of a command line we'll
spend a lot of time
in our terminal today so docker run is
the way to start a container
um in this case i'm running a container
in detached mode so running it in the
background
i'll always always use a dash dash rm
flag that's a
pro tip there when you're using
containers it takes up a lot of disk
space because
you've got all of those um those big as
i said kind of those big zip files that
are cached on your laptop or on your
hard drive
so it takes up a lot of space so by
using dash dash rm it makes sure that
it cleans up everything afterwards you
can give it a name
so if you start scripting um and and um
yeah if you want to automate some stuff
with your containers you can give them a
name so it's a lot easier
so i have a small script that i have set
up on my machine
where i just start type start nginx
and it starts a a container running
nginx
serving files from the folder in which i
am so that's very useful if i want to
test out
i have a static website that i want to
test out
my blog site and my my blog for example
i want to just update a page um then i
can start that
that server running serve local files
then i can just
use a localhost 8080 and i can see the
the result
when i'm done i just type in stop nginx
and everything is
using named containers so it makes it a
lot easier to be able to manage that if
you don't give it a name it will have a
random name
so those are a little trickier if you
want to automate some stuff
cool you can do stuff like mounting a
volume so i can say well take
the pwd as the current working folder on
my machine
and mount that into the slash app folder
inside my container so as far as my
container is concerned
the slash app folder will have the the
files from
my local file system so i'm really
mounting that um and faking that
um the slash app folder it's not a real
folder inside my container anymore it's
really
my local file system that is there so
that is very useful once again if you
want to mount a or start an apache
server
then you can mount a local file system
into slash var slash www.html
and then you can serve the files from
your local file system
you can also mount or map some ports so
in this case i'm saying well the port
3000 on my local machine
will map to the port 3000 in our
container
that works well if you're using once
again if you're using nginx
nginx will run on port 80 by default but
you cannot serve anything from port 80
on your local machine so you'll want to
mount
map a port something like 8080 on your
local host
that will map to port 80 inside that
container
so now if you do that that port mapping
you'll be able to use localhost 8080
and that will map inside your container
to the port 80.
then you can specify a base image so
containers are all about base images so
basically you always start
from an image in this case i'm starting
from an image called node 14.
uh there are many many different images
that are available
let me pull up my browser once again
where is it there it is you can go to
hub.marker.com
and you'll see a lot of different images
so if you want to start
a node.js project and containerize that
you'll find official images
always look for official images if you
can or else somebody will end up
mining bitcoins on your laptop
and and you find here all the different
versions so if you want to test out
the latest version of node 15 for
example well there it is you can you can
start a container you're running
note 15 i was using note 14 in my demo
that's what i'll be using today
and there's a lot of information on how
to use those containers
so start with a base image so if you
want to
uh if you want to run a i'll use php and
javascript examples but if you want to
run php there's
a php 7.4 image that you can use
and start using php right away with your
container
and finally you specify what is the
command that you want to be executed
inside that container once
the container is started so in this case
i'm using node slash app
which will start my index.js file in the
slash app folder which was map
from my file system right here
you can also build docker files which
will be a way for you to create your
own big zip file so but in this case
we've used a
a pre-built base image so we've used
note 14
but i could also package my own image so
that i would not only have
a note 14 in there but i would also have
all of my source code
so you can start from a base image you
will expose the different ports that you
need to
change your working directory i copy
files from my local file system
into that container then run different
commands to set up your machine so run
npm install in this case
and that will download half of the
internet basically
install all of that into the node
modules inside that container not on
your machine so all inside that that
container
and that's it you have that that big
container that big zip file that is
ready to be shipped
and finally use cmd to say when a user
uses docker run
this is the command that you will start
so npm start will actually start the
um the node.js server or whatever it is
that you have running there
um i see that people are joining in the
waiting room so let me just
make sure that i accept everyone there
it is
okay so um good
so this is kind of how it works once you
have your docker file you can use docker
build which will
kind of compile that into an image that
can then be uh used and then
you push that into a shared registry and
then you can use docker run
so in this case i will actually be using
an example
of that hands-on kubernetes say hello
let me actually open it up right here
it's not right there where is it uh not
there
i need to find my files uh
[Music]
let me just find it
all right there's another vs code window
there it is
okay so in here i
will be giving you examples on node
we'll have an image we have
a tiny application called say hello
right here so that's uh it's all
javascript node.js
and it just logs some stuff so it every
15 seconds
it logs hello world from the host name
and it will also add a timestamp to it
so that's all it does so it's just every
15 seconds it outputs that
i built a docker file for it so from
node 14
changing my working directory copying
the files running npm install
not that there's anything to install but
still and then i just
run a command node dot and that will
start our
index.js so i i did the uh
where's my slide deck so i did docker
build
um so that built my container and then i
did a docker push so that it's now
available on docker hub
and then you can use dr ron joel or
slash hands on kubernetes say hello
and that will actually run that
container inside your
on your local machine
all right let's see if we have anything
in the chat oh good
perfect all right if you want to learn
more about containers
because that's really not the topic but
i know that a lot of
containers are getting more and more
traction but especially with
large enterprise developers and a lot of
javascript developers are
are not on the haven't started using
them yet
um so if you want to find out more easy
url to slash containers
there is a talk that i give on
containers or you can search on youtube
for containerization for
software developers you'll be able to
find
a recording there there's a few links to
help you
there's a link for a cheat sheet that
describes all the different commands
that you can use and so on
so find out more on containers right
there
let me actually just paste this in
and right here all right
so enough about containers let's talk
about kubernetes because that's the
topic for today and i'm already 20
minutes in and i haven't started talking
about kubernetes so what is kubernetes
kubernetes is an open source system for
automating deployment scaling management
and containerized
application um so what does it do
basically
kubernetes ensure that pods um a pod
we'll talk about pods a little bit later
but for now you can assume that a pod is
equivalent to a container so it ensures
that those spots are always running
it'll make scaling your application a
lot easier
and it takes care of all the networking
between those different pods so when
you start having multiple containers you
have a database you have your api you've
got your front end
you'll need a way to start networking
between those different pods
and kubernetes will take care of all of
that for you and we'll see that in a few
minutes
the first thing that we the first
concept that we'll introduce is the
concept of a node
uh not to be confused with node.js so a
node in kubernetes is
i will run your workload by placing
containers into pods
to run on nodes so a node will be either
virtual or physical machine depending on
the cluster
each node contains the services
necessary to run pods managed by the
control plane
typically you have several nodes in a
cluster in a learning or resource
limited environment you might have just
one
so uh when i say kubernetes has a steep
learning curve
all the documentation is kind of dry and
looks a little bit like this so this was
taken directly from the documentation
so basically what a note is is just a
virtual machine or
a physical machine it could be it could
be a physical one but typically a
virtual one
um and and it's so you have two types of
nodes
do i have no i don't have the details of
the nodes um so you have two
types so you've got masternodes which
are in charge of dispatching
all of your containers all of your pods
into multiple worker nodes
those worker nodes the only thing that
they will do is to
keep or make sure that those those
containers are up and running it will
run
on those physical machines and your
masternode will be in charge of
making sure to dispatch based on the
allocate resource allocation on your
different machines
and will make sure that everything is
working correctly so it's kind of the
um how's it going
anyways okay so um
orchestrator uh i guess
okay so uh so this is what a note is uh
as i mentioned i
am using mini cube hopefully uh some of
you have already installed mini cube so
you're able to
to use it you can do if you have mini
cube and cube ctl you can use cube ctl
get nodes and that should show you what
nodes you have running on your machine
so in my case i have a
single node it's a limited environment i
have mini cube running
i have version 1.19 of kubernetes so you
can see the different nodes that you
have in your system
if you connect cube ctl to your cluster
to uh in the cloud
you might have multiple nodes then
typically you would have
uh three masters three workers for
redundancy
uh but right now i only have one
all right out of curiosity who is
following along with
uh mini cube who has it installed um so
let me know in the chat just so that i
know
also at any given time let me know if uh
if you need to
uh if you need for me to pause or go
slower go faster
feel free to use the chat i'm monitoring
it
install docker mini cube cube ctl
following along i have installed perfect
so we've got a few people
um going along let me know if there's
anything
if i go too fast or not fast enough
all right we've got a lot of people
following along that's great that's
great a lot of people tend to just
watch online presentations but i'm glad
that people are
wow okay so we've got at least 10 people
following along that's great
okay so let's talk about pods so ipods
are the smallest deployable unit of
computing that you can create and manage
in kubernetes
a pod as in a pot of whales you know
docker
wells pot of whales is a group of more
one or more containers with shared
storage network resources and a
specification on how to run
those containers so basically a
um
so somebody's having an error the
connection to server localhost 8080
i'm not sure what you're trying to run
here um
so if you want to add more details i'll
try to debug you
uh or not we'll just move on um so a pod
is a one or multiple containers so you
might have multiple containers if they
are
very tightly connected one to each other
um
yep mini cube start is the first thing
that you'll need to do
and then you'll be able to use cube ctl
sorry about that i forgot to mention
that
um so a pod will have multiple one or
multiple containers
an example of a pod with multiple
containers could be
if you have a mysql database and you
want to have a php my admin
to manage your your mysql database so
those are so tightly
connected one to each other that you can
put them inside the same pod
but typically one pod one container um
and and you would use that
use it that way okay so let's talk about
a pod let's actually
let me just find my code window again
that's the one i'm going to use here
that's the one that i'm going to cheat
and look at
so there it is perfect
so let's go ahead and create our first
spot so
what i did here i just um
up another terminal window
okay i just created a lab folder there's
nothing in there for now
and let's just go ahead and open up vs
code in my case i'm gonna start a create
a new file we're gonna use a
yaml file so the first one will be
called one.yaml
not very original and let's go ahead and
create our first kubernetes object
so kubernetes objects always always have
the same
they always work the same way so first
of all you have an api version
then you have a kind so you're creating
an object you have to specify what kind
of object that you're
actually creating
and then we have a metadata
and meta i i can never type that word i
don't know why it just doesn't
work with my brain okay metadata and
then we have a spec so all a kubernetes
object will have that
same definition so for our pod let's
start with
the api version version one we'll create
an object of kind
pod for the metadata you will have two
things in here you'll have a name
and labels let's talk about labels later
but just give it we'll just give it a
name for now so we'll call it hello
we'll go with a hello world example
and in our spec we will create an array
of containers so we can have one or
multiple containers
in this case we will have um
we will have a single container let me
just make sure that i have that
chat window open to see if people are
talking uh so containers and
you use a little dash to create an item
in your array in yaml
hopefully everybody is somewhat familiar
with yaml it is
um yeah yeah
all right so our first container will
have a name as well so we'll also call
it hello just um
just for why not um and then we'll use
the image note 14. so you need to start
or create an image or use an image for
your container
so this could be you know the one that i
created earlier or i can just use
note 14 directly once that container
starts
we will run the command slash bin slash
bash
with the argument dash c and the
argument dash dash
so what this will let us do is to run a
command
after that with the following arguments
and the arguments here and i'll i'll
copy that in the chat in just a few
seconds so we'll use node
e so we'll just run a node.js command
and whoops
the command that we will run will be
console log
hello world and we'll do a set timeout
and now i've got to make sure that i've
got all my parenthesis at the right
place that's
always the challenge okay so this
console
log terminating
and we'll give it a
30 second pause 30 seconds
parenthesis semicolon
end of the quote another quote there
all right let me paste that one in
because if you're trying to follow
here that's going to be a little bit
tricky uh go there you go
so uh so we've got this running um what
else do we need here
i think that's it so we've got our first
pod definition so this is what a pod
will look like
so it will create a single container in
there
that will use the node 14 image and it
will
run this node evaluation and will output
hello world
and then terminate after 30 seconds
so let's go ahead and use cube ctl and
we will use qctl apply so apply will
take that
yaml file and just throw that back into
our kubernetes cluster
dash f to say we're going to use a file
here and i'm going to use
one.yaml so this is the file that i want
to apply
inside my coordinates cluster so i've
got my response
pod hello is created so if i do cube ctl
get all i will see all the objects that
i have inside my kubernetes cluster
and i can see that i have well one pod
that's all i have
there's also the service kubernetes
that's because kubernetes has an api so
when i'm injecting stuff by using cube
ctl it actually uses
um this api uh but you can kind of
ignore it for now
so this is what i have i have my pod
hello um
one other thing that you can do with
cubectl is cubectl logs
and that will look for a pod called
hello and i can see that
it said hello world i can also use it
with dash f
that should uh track in any time that
there's a change so if there's another
entry that is console logged
so we should see a terminating in just a
few
seconds um it should be displayed in
real time there
well it should did i type in 30 seconds
or 300 seconds no
okay there it is so terminating so you
saw how that
um that pod started it ran that eval
on node.js it ran it did that console
log
and then console.log terminating after
30 seconds and that is the end of our
node process
here's something interesting if you do
cube ctl get all again
you will see that we still have that pod
running uh it's ready running
but it says restarts here restarts two
so it restarted two times already
because it's been running for 80 83
seconds
so after 30 seconds that note process
stops and the container just stops
because there is nothing else to do
so the container stops and kubernetes
wants to keep those pods alive so that
is one of the things that kubernetes
will try to do
so when it detects that that container
stopped it immediately restarted that
container so it's always being restarted
after 30 seconds
so that there's always something running
can i paste in my yaml config file yes i
can
let me just paste it in right here
that's a good idea so i'll just paste in
the full yaml files
we're not going to get the spacing right
let me just share something else here
um
hands-on this is my first time giving
this workshop so there's still a few
adjustments so thank you very much for
your patience
um right here i have
there we go
now i believe that there is value in
following along nope that's not the
right one there it is
all right so um so that's why i don't
want to share
all of my github repo right away but you
can probably figure out where everything
else is
uh cubectl apply dash f
dash f1.yaml was the command that was
ran to start that pod running
okay so let's just wait one second to
see if everybody can
run this this
pod and let me know by using
the uh the yes or the
yeah let's let me know by using the yes
to tell me if it worked
um if i have enough people that have yes
then i'll just
start moving along
we've got a few yeses uh
i'll wait a few seconds because i don't
have a lot of yeses
all right so let me know if there's
anything else that you need
from me so i've shared the github repo
that has
the one.yaml file so you can copy
from there you can then use cubectl
apply dashf1.yaml
and that should apply the yaml file
all right let's just wait a few seconds
here
i'm going for a drink every time i wait
them it's going to be a
long day
all right so you apply the the flag you
apply the
okay so cube ctl apply dash f
one dot yaml should be the command to
apply
and to create that pod once you've
applied it
cube ctl get pods
should show you the pods so cube ctl
get pods will give you this or something
like this
something like this uh actually i
technically did cube ctl get all
um but it's the same thing you can see
that after a point when uh kubernetes
detects that it's always crashing it
will stop and just give you a crash
loop back off message uh so it started
four times and then it stopped
running
uh good point one there is a way to
create them with deployments i'll get
back to that don't worry
so we're just starting with the basics
right now so we're looking at a pod what
it is
uh how it's working uh once you have
your pot you can also use
um cubes ctl logs
hello dash f and you should see the logs
of your pod in real time
all right so i'll move along let me try
to
show you another example so the other
will create another file here
so just a second file called 2.yaml
and it will have the same structure once
again so api version kind
um metadata and spec
so um if i keep losing my
there it is my cheat sheet um
perfect um there it is okay
so let's create a second pod and that
part will run a web server so it will
run a nginx
uh the dash f for the logs is just to
get them in real time so it's like a
tail
i can't remember what f stands for but
you could just use a
cube ctl logs hello and it will just
output the log so far
so for our server here api version v1
so it will start the same way we will
create an object of kind pod
oops here's a quick tip if you installed
the extension
the vs code extension you'll be able to
simply by using pod to create
all of the pod so you've got all the
definition here but let's keep to this
i will create an object of kind pod we
will add some metadata metadata i told
you i
can't spell that word and we will name
it web server
now for the spec we will have an array
of containers once again so very similar
to what we did before
we'll just give it a name we'll call it
nginx and we will use the image
nginx 1.17
all right i'm using 1.17 just because
it's cached on my machine doesn't really
matter if you didn't put a version
number here it would just use the latest
version which i believe is 1.19
at this point uh
let me find the
actual file so that you can paste it in
if you want to
um there it is
and here it is okay so if you want to
just copy it from there
or you can type it in right like it is
right there
so i've got my yaml file i am ready to
go back to my terminal
in here i will use cube ctl apply dash f
again so exactly the same way so we're
going to apply that new file
and we're going to use 2.yaml in this
case
and we should see pod web server created
so that means that if we do cube ctl get
all
we should now see two pods plus our
kubernetes service
and there it is and that one is running
uh it doesn't seem like it's restarting
so that's good so we've got a nginx
server
running right now
so what can we do with our web server
right now
well one command that we can use um
is cube ctl exec dash i t
so if you've used docker you've probably
you'll probably recognize that command
so basically it lets you
execute a command on that pod and we'll
run that on the pod web server
and dash dash is the command that we
will run inside that container or inside
that pod
so we will run slash bin slash bash so
this will open up a bash session so
we'll be able to
kind of log inside of that container
let me paste this in right here and
let's run it
all right so i'm now logged into my web
server you can see i'm logged in as a
root
if i do something like service nginx
status
i can see that my nginx server is
up and running uh if i do a
curl local host well i don't have curl
installed in there but
um so i've got that web server running i
should be able to now uh
to curl it to see the content of it but
if i
exit there is no way for me to actually
be able to reach
that web server so this is where we'll
need some networking and this is where
kubernetes will come and help us
uh with the networking part so for now
let's keep that web server
right there let's keep it running
and let's take a look at what else we
have here
um okay
so just looking where i'm at perfect
so let's create another object we'll
create a third object and we'll create a
toolbox that will actually have a curl
installed so that we can use that to
test out our web services
let's go ahead create a third file
3.yaml
and actually let's change that and
rename that to
3.json because
because kubernetes had an api and it
actually
uses json-based api you can
also use json file so it will use the
json directly
if you're using a yaml behind the scenes
it actually parses it into a json file
and because we're all js developers here
i figured you might be interested in
using json instead now
at first i thought that json would be
easier to use just because i'm more
familiar with the syntax
but you quickly get lost into all of
those
um
quotes and commas and and
i think yaml kind of makes sense like it
took me a while to get convinced of that
but
i guess it kind of does so we can go
ahead and create our object it will have
the same structure
except that we're going to use json in
this case
somebody says please no json you can
actually do it in in
yaml if you if you want if you're up for
a challenge
so we'll create an object called toolbox
and
once again let me just cheat right here
for the spec spec
will have no no we'll have an object
that will have a containers array so you
can see how
oh it's starting to uh it will quickly
get missy
so we'll create our first container here
this one will have a name we'll call it
toolbox
it will have an image for the image i'll
use registry.access.redhat.com.com yep
slash ub8 so that's the universal base
image from red hat
it comes with a few tooling stuff like
ping
and curls that will be able to use that
and then we have our command our command
was an array
um it will use slash i'll copy and paste
all of that
so slash bin slash bash dash c
dash dash and
we will have some arguments
and what i'll do here for my arguments
i'll just use a little bash script
i'll just say while true
do sleep 30 done
all right 2 sleep 30 done perfect so
what this will do is that it'll just
create an infinite loop
and it will just sleep for 30 seconds
every time um
so that will just keep a process up and
running so that can our container won't
stop
all the time just like it did before
with our first pod it kept stopping
so this one will just always
continuously be working
all right so where is the actual file
let's find it right
here we've got a 3.2 box
this is my json file you can use that
and let's go back to our terminal use
cube ctl again cube ctl apply dash
f uh three dot yammer3.json
and it created our toolbox so you can
see that you can use
um either yaml or json whatever you're
more comfortable with
json gets a little bit tricky so let's
do cube ctl get pods we should now see
our toolbox so that's good
um why don't we log inside that toolbox
with cubectl exec just like we did
before
toolbox or just read.red hat dot io
thank you
you're exactly right that's why i was
confused between the dot com or dot io
there
and we'll run a slash bin slash bash i'm
now inside my toolbox
so i can technically do something like
curl
web server still can't reach that web
server
so here's one thing i can do so i can
exit from here
i can cube ctl back
into my web server get hostname
dash i dash i that'll give me
the internal ip address for this
web server and now i can go back into my
toolbox
curl 17217 and there you go so i can now
connect
to that web server that was there
oh and i am i still there because i see
the image being frozen
inside zoom so let me just
give me a wave if you can still hear me
frozen as well
can hear i can hear but image is frozen
that's weird uh maybe dan can help me
out
uh we'll see
okay perfect so we've got our
magic dan helping us right now uh trying
to get that image frozen in the meantime
um
so what i was able to do basically is to
uh log into that
um there it is it's back so
thank you so much um so i was able to
log inside that toolbox and i'm now able
to do a curl to that web server
so i can communicate to those web
servers through their ip addresses
but now we'll need to create a way to uh
so that we're able to use there's an
internal dns that we'll be able to use
and start
naming those services so i got the ip
address by
logging inside the
um logging inside the uh
the web server and using hostname dash i
okay so we've got someone there's a
small issue here
to slash binable to upgrade connection
container not
found what about cube ctl
get all and make sure that you actually
have
that pod running so pod slash toolbox
should be running
cubectl exec it
toolbox dash bin
should let you in
and copy
error image pool there
okay so here's that's actually a good
point um which i didn't plan on talking
about today but
if you do cube ctl describe that will
is actually a way to get more
information so when when you're having
issues with one of your containers you
can use that
uh pod slash toolbox and that will give
you
all the different events and and to kind
of tell you what is
going on i suspect that i might be
logged into the red hat registry at this
point
uh which might be why i am successfully
able to pull that image but you're not
in the end it doesn't really matter if
you're not able to
run that pod um as we won't be using it
anymore i kind of wanted to show you how
you can connect and do that networking
uh internally but uh we can still move
on um
with the next step which is what i'll do
at this point
uh if you want to come back to those
spots and try them out feel free to um
come back afterwards but now i want to
introduce the concept of deployment
so what is a deployment well pods biomes
themselves are kind of
useless so you saw how um oh it worked
in the end perfect
so pause by themselves um you you
you know it's hard to maintain them and
ultimately the goal is to be able to
scale right
so if you you need a way to figure out
how you're going to spin up more
pods and and all of that stuff so you
typically wouldn't use pods directly
so it was it was a nice intro so that
you're able to play with them
see what they're actually doing but now
is the time to introduce a deployment so
deployment provides the declarative
updates for pods of replica sets
so the description on the kubernetes
distribution is you describe a desired
state in the deployment
and the deployment controller changes
the actual state to the desired state at
the controller rate controlled array
you can define deployments to create new
replica sets or to remove existing
deployments and adopt all of their
resources
with new deployments is that clear
so essentially what a deployment does is
that you kind of describe
what you want what are the pods that you
want running and how many of them
running that you want and all that stuff
once that is sent to
your kubernetes cluster kubernetes will
take care of creating a replica set and
their job of a replica set is making
sure that those spots are always
up and running so make sure that you
always have the number of buzz that you
want
and it will create them or destroy them
as
needed so why don't we go ahead and go
back to our editor here
create a new file we'll call it 4.yaml
there it is so we'll use the same syntax
so we'll create a deployment this time
but it is using the same syntax so api
version
i believe it's not using v1 though so
let's just find it right here perfect so
it's apps
slash v1 we'll create an object of kind
deployment
our metadata we data
we'll give it a name and we'll call it
hello
so it's a deployment called hello
and we have our spec once again the bulk
of the logic of our
our our diff object definition will go
into the spec
in here we will say well first of all
create some containers using the
following template
so this is the template for our
container so basically everything that
we would put inside of our pod
we will put inside the template so it
will have a metadata
just like we did for our pods but now
we'll start using
labels so the label instead of giving it
a name i'll give it some labels and i'll
say well
labels are arbitrary you can give it
whatever you want so in this
in this case i'll say well this spot
will have one job and
his job will be to say hello so this is
the label that i'll use
um and now i'm
going to add the spec for my pod
so for the spec we will have a
containers array
just like we did for our pods so
remember right here is
pretty much exactly what we did right
here
all right so we'll have an array of
containers
our first container will have the name
hello
and we'll use the image joellord
that's me slash hands-on
kates or kubernetes slash say
hello all right so let me just
find the actual
[Music]
code i saw that i had a question i'll
get back to that in just a few seconds
i get easily distracted by questions so
i'll just
finish my deployment and then i'll come
back to various questions
not this one where am i going zoom zoom
meeting
there it is boom okay
so i've got my deployment let's go ahead
and
apply that to our kubernetes cluster so
cube ctl apply
dash f 4 dot yaml
and i have an error all right
right i forgot one thing let me get back
to my
vs code
there it is okay so i specified this
the the template but i also need to tell
my
my um my deployment
that you will be watching for pods that
match the following
description so i'll add a selector
and i'll say watch for pods that match
the following labels
so that is job say hello all right
so our deployment will be monitoring the
pods that have the label
job equals say hello and those are
described right here in our template
so this should not work let me go back
to my terminal or reapply this file
and there it is so my deployment is
created
now the interesting part is cubectl
getall
once again and you can see that we've
got a lot more stuff now
so we've got our deployment right here
so it created our deployment our crea
our deployment is requiring one pod
um so it's available it also created a
replica set so you can see here we've
got our replica set
and the name is hello dash 66b6
that is a random number that should have
been assigned to you
so it might be different on your machine
and that replica set is in charge of
making sure that we have
one desired pod so always have one pod
ready so right now we currently have one
that's good
and we can see that we have a pod hello
dash 66b6 blah blah blah
which is our replica set and it's it
assigned
a new random number to it all right
so we can all see all the different pods
that we have here here's another command
that you can use cube ctl
get pods dash l so give me all the pods
with the
label matching job equals say hello
and that should give us a single pod
right here
right so let me just paste that in
the chat right here so you can test it
out
and we can also similarly use cube ctl
logs dash l job equals say hello
and we will see the logs from this pod
i can use dash f as well so i'll be
seeing them in real time so every 15
seconds i should see a new line
coming out so that's the application
that i've shown you at the beginning
when i was talking about containers
all right let's take a quick look at the
questions so um
all right so it seems like it worked
labels are contrary completely arbitrary
yes
there are some best practices on how to
use them um you know using app
equals something for certain spaces that
you can look up best practices for
labeling and applications but it is
completely arbitrary completely up to
you um to decide what you want to do
okay so we've got this part running um
we've got
um our deployment running so let's see
what we can do with that deployment cube
ctl
scale is kind of neat so you can use
cube ctl scale
that will apply on our deployment hello
so the name of our deployment and we can
say replicas
equals 10.
can pod yaml files be referenced from
deployment yaml files
not that i know of but i might be
completely wrong there
all right so this is the command to
scale up your application
and if i try this application was scaled
let's do cube ctl get all again
and you can see that we've got a lot
more stuff so we've got all those
containers they're all container
creating at the moment
and now if i run that logs
again i'm attempting to follow 10 so i
can do
max log
requests requests equals then
um and now i should see all of my logs
so you can see that um i'm
outputting the name of the or the host
name right here so g j
g or svh and so on
so they're all outputting and you can
see that there's an output from each one
of them every 15 seconds
so this is why you will typically use
deployments instead of pods so that you
have a lot more control
on how those spots are going to run
inside of your cluster
i can run cubectl scale
deployment slash
hello replicas and let's bring it
back down to two replicas cube ctl get
all quick
and then you can see that our replica
set is trying to terminate all of those
so it'll try to gracefully terminate all
of our pods and it'll just keep two of
them running so pxx
and five m zed no
[Music]
if n s sv should be running so if i do
it again
in just a few seconds they should be
turned off and we should be back to
uh only two replicas at this point
any time now
all right so we can now create
deployments and you can see how
deployments map to
um to our um
to our pods
and let's go ahead and create a real
application this time
now i have a um front end that was
created with vue.js
and we will and everything is already in
a container so
it doesn't really matter what it was
created with but basically i've used
vue.js and i've created a container with
a nginx server
with the static files that came out of
the build process
so if you look at my talk
containerization for software developers
you will see how i actually
created that docker file
so let's go ahead and create a new file
here we'll call it five.yaml
and we will use the same type of
structure
so first of all we'll have api version
v1 we will sorry that's apps
slash v1 we will create an object of
kind
deployment
we will have some metadata now we're
creating a real object so let's
make that a little bit more um you know
real life
like so we'll give it a name we'll call
it front
because that's our front end and we'll
give it a label as well so labels
app hands-on
kubernetes let me just put that right
here just like i have
in my cheat sheet right here okay now on
for our spec
so the spec for our
for our deployment we'll we'll specify
right away that we want two replicas
instead of using that our scale we can
immediately put in
um
can you summarize shortly what a
deployment is sorry ignore so deployment
um
shortly i'll still mention it um is a
just basically the the plan or the
schedule that you want for your pods
like it just describes what are the
parts that you want and how many you
want at any given time
okay so um right here
we will have our selector once again for
our deployment so it will
look for pods that have
a match labels so looking for pods that
will have the following label
we'll say section front so uh any pods
that have
that label so any parts that are for our
front end
will be matched here and now here's the
template for the pods that we want to
create
so let's put in some metadata we will uh
not a name but we'll have some labels
those pods will also be part of the
application hands-on kubernetes
so you can apply that label to as many
objects that you want but they will also
have section
front so this is important so that this
label matches
those pods now that i'm done with my
metadata
i'll go on with my spec
and we will have containers
our first container will have name front
and we'll use the image
joe lord slash hands on
clear dash there hands on
kubernetes dash front
right so this is the name of the image
that image is already pushed on docker
hub
so you should be able to pull it and now
i can do
ports and this image is running
container port 8080.
all right so this is my deployment let
me
paste that in or the link for it in just
a few seconds
right here and back to zoom
i keep losing my zoom window there it is
okay so if we go back to our terminal
cube ctl apply dash f once again and
we'll apply
five dot yaml it created our front
deployment so cube ctl
cube ctl get all
and we can see that we've got our front
so we've got
two containers running with that front
end
all right so we can now create
deployments
i am ready so there's a problem with
still with our
our services that um there's no way to
reach them yet so we
still can't reach our web server we
still can't reach our front end
so this is what we're gonna do we're
gonna slowly introduce services
before i jump to services is there any
questions i'll let you one second to
type it in
seems like we're good so far
also as i mentioned it's my first time
giving this workshop especially in the
virtual world it's a little bit
different
to give for workshops um so any feedback
is always appreciated feel free to um
send any positive feedback on on twitter
so that my bosses also see it so joel
underscore underscore lord
or send me a dm for constructive
feedback so i can
make this a little bit better for next
time uh or if you have negative
feedback just keep it to yourself
okay so no questions so far so let's
move on to services which is the third
really core concept that i wanted to
introduce today once we're done with
those um
everything else is is kind of just
extras so let's talk about services so
service is
a abstract way to expose an application
running on a set of pods as a network
service
with kubernetes you don't need to modify
your application to use a unfamiliar
service discovery mechanism
kubernetes gives pods their own ip
addresses and a single dns name
for a set of pods and you can load
balance across them
okay so so remember when i
i went into the i i logged inside that
web server
i i did hostname dash i that gave me the
ip address of that specific
container or that specific pod now i was
able to go inside my toolbox
uh pod and from there i was able to curl
that ip address that's because there's a
whole
networking going on inside of that
inside of our kubernetes cluster so they
have their own ip addresses each pod has
their own ip address
but there was no way for me to just
directly address web server
so in order to do that we will need to
have a dns and there's one part of
kubernetes already
but we need to inject uh our our pods
inside our
service now the service will take a
deployment so we'll say well for
or take a set of pods and we'll say well
all of the pods
matching uh a specific label or however
we want to describe them
then send all the traffic to all those
spots so if we had
um in this case i have two front ends
running so two
nginx servers with my front and running
so i'll create a service so that it
sends all the traffic to uh what was it
called front
and it will do the load balancing
between those multiple containers
so really cool you can do it takes care
of all the load balancing for you takes
care of
internal dns and all that stuff so let's
go ahead
and jump into that just before that i
see that i have a question can we have a
shared node modules for all pods the
quick answer is
no um there is a way to create
shared spaces but really
the way that your container works you
should have your node modules
inside each one of your containers
once you've downloaded all of it it
stays there and and
can be reused it can also be cached so
it's much faster to reuse
but the node modules goes inside your
containers which then goes inside of
your pod
that is the typical way to do it
there i don't see a real advantage of
using a
shared node modules especially that some
of those node modules
will be compiled for a specific
operating system
which shouldn't be an issue because all
of those pods will be running linux but
it's it's a bet a better practice to put
all of your node modules inside
that container so hopefully that
answered that question um okay let's
move on with our services now
so uh for our service um i'll go back to
my terminal here
and we'll create a new file six dot yaml
i don't feel very original with my file
names today
so six dot yaml uh and in here we will
create an object of kind
service so api version again this is
version v1
kind service
metadata data
we will create uh well we'll name it
front so
nothing prevents us of reusing the same
names as long as it's
on different kind of objects so i can
only have one
deployment call front but i can have a
deployment call front and a service call
front
i like to keep the same names for things
that are related together so it makes it
easier to find them afterwards
i also give it some labels so this is
also part of the same application so
hands-on
case and then
we have the spec for our service
so in here i'll use a selector
so similar to what we did for our
deployment and i'll say use any label
matching
front section equals front right so
those are
all of our pods that have this specific
label and then i'll map some ports
so i'll say any traffic that comes to
service
we will expose the port
it's an array so one port port 80 80
too many 80s there and on protocol
tcp so basically i'm telling this
service
open up this port so you can accept now
traffic
coming to port 8080 through pcp protocol
to go to all of those containers and if
you remember correctly i'll just jump
here
very quickly we did expose our container
port right here
all right so that's port 8080 right here
uh it maps to
this port 8080 here let's go ahead and
deploy this
cubectl apply-f6
so our service is now created cubectl
getall should show our service so we got
our service
kubernetes which is the kubernetes api
but we also have this
new service here so what can we do now
that we have this service
um what i can do is that i can actually
jump into
my toolbox again so remember what i did
earlier
i was able to do a curl not everybody
managed to get the toolbox up and
running so i'll just
i'll just demo it for now and we can do
curl
front port 8080 and there you have it so
we've got
our um our server nginx server
replying us it sells yeah javascript is
not enabled
uh which kind of makes sense with a curl
but basically you have oh the link for
6. yaml you're right sorry
so basically you now have a service and
you see that i can now use the name
front because that was injected into our
dns
our dns that runs inside of our
kubernetes cluster
so i'm now able to contact some of those
service if i were to create a service
for my web server pod
i'd be able to use the same thing curl
web server and i would be able to reach
it
directly with the host name now what is
also really cool is that it will do load
balancing
we'll see that in a few seconds because
that application will also show us
uh what host it's running on all right
there's one final topic that i wanted to
introduce today which is called an
ingress which is how to
expose that service to the outside world
which is uh
where it starts to get a lot more fun
so yeah i still have 20 minutes to do
that should be plenty of time
is there any questions on services at
this point
uh having the same name as the section
is intentional
uh that is not intentional uh that is
just me being lazy with
uh my naming um i should i should really
uh work on that a little bit better so i
have different
names so i don't reuse the same thing
all the time but no there's there's no
no connection between the labels and the
name that i gave it is just
out of pure laziness
um can you repeat what is a service
definition i cannot repeat it because
really i don't remember what it was but
i can put it on the screen
so basically a service is a way to
um it's a way to create a a dns entry
for a set of pods basically
so a service is solely for internal use
you
are correct it is only for enter the
internal dns
so if you have multiple micro services
speaking to each other or talking to
each other
then you'll use those services so that
you can expose
those multiple um those those multiple
micro services to each other or through
a
um or a good example would be
um creating that for uh the uh
your messaging queue and then all of
them will be able to address the
messaging queue
through a dns name instead of having to
find
that uh that ip address through some
sort of discovery mechanism
how do you create a low balancer across
those pods
good question magic that's how it you do
it
so when you create a service it
automatically creates that load
balancing
across all of the different pods for um
for that that are exposed through that
service so everything is taken care of
for you automatically by using a service
so that's one of the really really cool
things about kubernetes i should have
put more emphasis on that
it really makes your life easier so you
don't have to
start doing that low balancing you can
specify as part of your service
how you want that load balancing done i
believe there are a few ways i am
familiar with the round robin which is
what is used by default
so basically it will send a request to
each one of the pods one after the other
but i believe there are ways to do it
with um the the current
um or on how busy they are and so on
is there a way to connect a specific pod
in a service
uh well you would do that through the
selector and uh
in this case i'm connecting a set of
through through some labels you could
have a single pod
and just give it a label and then you'd
be able to use that selector for that
specific pod as well
i mean send an http request um so
so this is what i did exactly right so
in here
i logged inside my toolbox and i
from my toolbox i was able to send an
http request
to a while to
not to a specific pod so if i was able
to send a request to my service which
then sent it
to a specific pod you can also send them
to a specific pod
i believe there is you would need to
find the ip address of it
and then you'd be able to send it to
that specific pod as well
but really what you want to do here is
to start using deployments and services
so that you don't have to find specific
pods that's the whole
point um how do you they say that it's
when you're using kubernetes it's not
about pets it's more about
cattle so you don't care about the
unique individuals you don't care about
those pods anymore but you really you
care about
the whole group of pods that you have so
it doesn't so in this case what's really
cool about that is that
if one of those pods crashes for some
reason if someone manages to
get into that pod and to you know do
something to it and and it crashes the
pod
well it will recuperate will
automatically automatically take care of
restarting that pod and so now it will
have a random name it will have a
different ip address it will have
everything will be different but you'll
still have a pod up and running so you
have to make sure that they are
stateless and that they can be restarted
easily so that's really
the key to when you're starting to use
kubernetes but
uh but yeah and at that point you would
even if it's just a single pod you will
still create
a deployment for one single pod and you
would create a service for that pod
so that it would always be exposed
through that service which makes it
easier for the discovery
of that single pod so that's kind of how
you would do it even if you had one
specific pod that you want to address
so you could do those http requests to
those pods
now if you want to do an external
request from the outside world from the
public internet into that cluster
well this is exactly what we're going to
look at right now
to do so you will need an ingress so
that was a nice way to
get into that sounding grass is an api
object that manages external access to
the services in a cluster typically
through
http ingress may provide low balancing
ssl termination and name based virtual
hosting so basically
what you're doing here is that we will
establish a set of rules
so those rules could be based on the
domain name so
you could do some routing based on you
know any incoming request to
www.mydomain.com will be
redirected to my front service and any
request to api.mydomain.com will be sent
to
my api service so you can redirect based
on a bunch of different rules
you can also use the routing so this is
what i'll
be using here actually i won't have the
time to
show you how to use it with the api but
i'll kind of show it very quickly at the
end
but i'll be able to route my traffic to
slash
into my front service and to slash api
something else to my api
so you can create all those rules to
expose the different services that
you have running in your system
so i'll just go ahead i'll pick up the
base a little bit
so let's go into
[Music]
right here i'll find the seven dot yaml
and there it is where's my zoom
zoom is here there you go
and i will also just paste it in
to my editor right here
so seven dot yaml all right
so api version networking.kubernetes.io
um we will create an object of kind
ingress
which will expose everything to our
outside world i'll give it a name so
it's my main ingress
rewrite target will be used in the more
advanced
ingresses but i won't have the time
really to cover that i'll quickly show
it afterwards
and then you specify all the rules that
you have for your ingress
so in this case i'll do some rules based
on the http protocol
i will make the rules based on the paths
for
my incoming request so any requesting
coming to slash
will be sent to this back end so to the
front end so that terminology here is a
little bit confusing so a backend is
something or some sort of service inside
of our kubernetes cluster
so in this case i'm using service front
and to the port 8080
so any incoming request to my kubernetes
cluster on port 80
will be redirected to the front service
on port 8080 right here so that is all
done
internally through some port mapping so
let's go ahead and apply this
cube ctl apply dash f7
and we've got our ingress fun thing here
cube ctl get all you won't see the
ingresses in get all so
get all will show your pods services
deployments and replica sets
if you want to see your ingresses get
ingresses
you can see them right here
um all right so we've got our main uh
main service here so what that means is
that i can now in theory
from here oh let's just use mini cube
cube ip all right so that gives me the
internal ip address for my mini cube
virtual machine running on my laptop so
now i can do curl localhost
no not localhost i can curl that ip
address
and i can now contact my
front end if i open up
a window right here paste it in
that ip address i can now see my
application it is exposed to the real
world
and here i can see the name of the pot
that answered that request so the front
end
hd jfr if i
fun fact if i refresh
oh there you go so now this request was
answered
by zdh7n and in theory if i refresh
again it should always be
a different one so there's that load
balancing for you so
all that low balancing is done
automatically through our service
so you can see here that it's a
different service answering every time
what i wanted to do as well was to
create that api right now i won't have
the time to deploy all of that
but i'll still quickly go through that
uh code with you
so just to give you an idea and if you
want to do it on your own
you'll be able to do it afterwards so we
did seven
eight is our deployment for our api
right here uh so i'll share the github
repo at the end
so this is the deployment very very
similar to the deployment so you'll see
that
those deployments are always pretty much
the same thing but the main difference
here is that i'm using a different image
as well as a different port because my
api is built on
node.js you can also add more than one
object
inside a single file so i can separate
those by the three
dashes here i can also create my service
for my api
so very very similar to the other one
again but you can see that this one this
service is on
port 3000. i have my
yeah with my 9.yaml here
and that is our advanced ingress so
let's take a look at our ingress here
i've added
an extra rule on the path and i can see
that any incoming request to slash api
with an optional slash here and
everything afterwards
will be redirected to the service api
so it will be redirected to my api here
and i've kept uh the other front service
so any incoming request to
slash and there's a fee a little bit of
um regular expression voodoo here um so
just an empty object
just so that i can map with the object
number one here
and that's my object number one and any
incoming request
and the last rule is the rules are
always followed in order so if it finds
slash api
something it will be picked up by this
one and slash anything else will be
picked up
by my front end uh and now my rewrite
target that i had
earlier i just redirect everything to
or i rewrite my target to be slash the
second item in my regular expression so
what that means is that
it will take an incoming request to
slash api
hello redirect that to my service to the
api service
but remove that slash api and the
optional slash here part so it will just
remove that and it will just keep item
number two
which is anything else after the first
part of the route
uh so a little bit of regular expression
magic here that also works for a second
one so if i had
an internal router so a vue.js or react
application with an internal
with a router inside of the application
i would be able to use um
you know my front-end slash
slash whatever dashboard and then that
would be picked up
by that second route here
so now yeah now i use that advanced
ingress i can
add that afterwards and uh
what do i have here i have another
deployment for
um oh yes and then you can also add your
environment variables to your front-end
so this is what i'm doing here i'm
adding an environment variable to
specify
the base path for my api inside of my
front-end
so i'll just go ahead and apply those
files uh
dash f uh they were in my rehearsal
um nine
and ten and everything should now be up
and running i now have
my application running you can see how
i'm getting the response from a
different
server so nw wasn't there before that's
because i added those new environment
variables so it
kubernetes immediately took care of
starting two new pods
and trying to gracefully terminate the
other parts that were existing before
and now i can contact the api and i can
see that
my request is done to hello and it was
answered by
this specific pod right here by api
slash yada yada
so cube ctl get all
uh you can see i now have a bunch of
different things i've got my
api pod running i've got two services
i've got
two well two more deployments
and my new services are all there my
replica sets
and my ingress was changed to
accommodate all of that
if you are following this and looking at
the recording
um and just for fun um you will find in
the readme file
there is a another api that you can add
so there's a little challenge there for
you
so you can take a look at the readme on
my github repo you'll see there's
another service that you can have for
an api that that just crashes so those
buttons here um
contact crashing api you'll be able to
deploy that api
change your ingress so that it picks up
that new route and
change the environment variables so that
it actually i can redirect traffic to
there
so here's that's a little challenge for
you uh let me see if there's any
questions here
i can i can see a few uh unable to
recognize for kind ingress in networking
uh all right i forgot that in minicube
you will need to do
you will need to do mini cube
add-ons enable ingress
i believe is the way to do it um
let me just copy this um
yeah it's already enabled for me so
that's good yes i forgot that make sure
that you enable
the ingress add-on so mini cube is a
stripped-down version of kubernetes that
it can run on your
on your local machine but it doesn't
have all of the features of
kubernetes so you need to install some
of the add-ons
when you want to go with a more advanced
topics i'd say
so ingressos is one of those so where
you need to actually enable the add-on
first um
you can also try v1 beta1 it wasn't
better until about a month ago so it was
just just released the new version
so the examples i've updated them
yesterday so that they actually use the
new version but yes you could be still
be able to use
version one beta one
gives another error that makes sense
mini cube add-ons enabled yep
okay uh thanks let me know if that works
uh out of curiosity
um that's all i had there was a lot of
content that was a lot of stuff that we
went through
uh firstly i thought i would go through
the whole example um
but still i went through the important
parts
uh where is my slide deck again in my
terminal there it is
uh so deploying the api uh so that's
that's all i have for today
um hopefully you've got a little bit of
a better idea
on what is kubernetes and how you can
start using it
really my goal is to give you enough
content so that you're able to start
googling stuff just looking at the
documentation can be a little bit tricky
like i said it's a little bit dry
drier than i wish it would be so it's
hard for someone new to the to the
kubernetes
fair to to come into uh but hopefully
you have enough information here
to get started i'll stick around for
another 10 minutes if you have any
questions
i will have to leave the room soon
though just
so that people can come in for the next
workshop
and you can go to the next one if you
want to or if you have another one
more information available on easy url
to slash hands-on dash
kubernetes there's a few links there you
can find my slide deck
so you'll be able to try out some of the
things
and feel free to reach out on twitter
twitter is always the best way to get in
touch with me more than happy to answer
any questions you might
have over there and like i said i'll
stick around for a few minutes
apart from that thank you very much for
being here hope you enjoyed the
conference
no conf is great unfortunately it would
have been nice to meet in person
but i'm glad this actually worked out
worked out better than i thought it
would
so thank you very much for attending and
hopefully see you next year